hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his work the Poetics Aristotle is
going to Define tragedy for us and in
that definition there's kind of a
interesting Clause a part of that
definition which has to do with the
function of tragedy how it works upon us
as Spectators or as people who are
experiencing it the effects of seeing a
play enacted
on a stage with actors and all of that
and what does Aristotle actually tell us
about this it has to do with our
emotions but not all of our emotions he
does talk about other emotions besides
these two but the two that he is
particularly interested in are fear
Phobos in Greek and pity Laos in Greek
and he tells us that tragedy part of
what what it is part of what it does its
Essence is that through fear and pity
and the word through there is D so you
know by the means of or through it
accomplishes
purification is usually how we translate
this catharsis of those very emotions of
those pathe those things that we
experience right that that then
affectively drive us and induce us to
not just feeling but sometimes thinking
and acting and purification here Airsoft
doesn't really explain what this is but
you know some people thought well it
helps to empty us it's a purgation of
these emotions quite literally it means
like a cleaning so perhaps it purifies
those emotions we'll leave that as side
for the moment and then we want to ask
an Aristotle answers this at many
different points in the Poetics Okay so
through fear and pity how are these
produced within a dramatic production a
tragedy and the first thing that he
talks about is what we translate as a
joint so in relation to each other
recognition Ana gonorises right and
reversal
peripetea literally like changing uh
round uh falling right and so
recognition is having known something
before but you know then it being you
being ignorant of it because of the
circumstances and suddenly you you
understand how things go so for example
when a character who you think is your
enemy is suddenly revealed to be your
long lost friend okay well there's uh
recognition or
worse off when uh Oedipus finds out that
he is the man who has caused the plague
on the city of Thebes by killing his own
father and marrying his own mother oh
that's terrible and that's also a
reversal as well so these cause as
Aristotle is going to say
um pity and fear when they're they're
done well a joint recognition and
reversal will yield either pity or fear
right depending on what the
circumstances are and we'll get into
that in a bit why would it
do one rather than the other
we go on a little bit further and we
find that Aristotle is actually going to
talk about two different things in a
passage about how we produce these uh
sorts of things
how do we generate
um
the the stuff well the structure the
sustasis this is the plot right and
recognition and reversal are also part
of the plot the muthos the most
important element of tragedy so the
sustasis of events he is going to tell
us
is part of how we grasp the these
matters and he talks about hearing
events that happen without even seeing
the play can arouse pity and fairness
now what's he talking about there
we would actually say reading because
in ancient times when somebody would
read they would read aloud and they
would often read aloud to other people
and so you would hear the play being
read by somebody right but we would read
it with our eyes in our own time so you
know the way in which the plot is
structured can help to produce these
emotions in the you know the right kind
of person some people are impervious to
this sort of thing and in that section
Aristotle is actually going to talk
about
not just the plot or the structure of
events but he's actually going to talk
about
um spectacle opsis which is one of the
elements of tragedy but Aristotle
considers it to be the the one that's
the sixth of six in importance right and
actually kind of kind of falling outside
of the poet's work it's more something
that another person would do and he
actually tells us that it has little to
do with the poet's art and it requires
material
resources right
um so it's it's not quite as
involved and he says those who use
spectacle to create an effect not only
of the fearful the things that strike
fear into us but also we could say of
the uh Sensational or the Monstrous
right
um so this he thinks it can work right
you can have a scary mask right you can
um make scary music to go along with it
or the stage could be all dark or
something you're down in Hades but for
the most part this is not what Aristotle
is interested in
now something that does pertain to the
actors and the direction is what gets
translated as gestures
um but we can see that it's not simply
gestures but also something deeper than
that so gestures are schemata right he
says so far is possible one should work
the plot out in gestures because
a natural Affinity
uh you know Oppo tastes out tastes fuse
he says
makes people those in the grip of
emotions the most convincing uh pitan
otatoi so an actor who is actually
feeling pity or fear uh can convey those
to us obviously we're not talking about
the hero in this case we're talking
about the other characters for example
the chorus in Greek tragedies oh whoa
you know this is terrible uh poor
Oedipus you know or whoever else it's
going to be right so that's part of it
but he's talking about how um well he
says the truest distress or anger using
these as examples is conveyed by one who
actually
feels these things
um
right is is uh the the term that he
brings up there and he talks about
um you know this can happen with all the
emotions
so the actors on stage
seeing how they're reacting hearing how
they're reacting the gestures of their
bodies can help us to feel pity and fear
and then finally we have one last thing
that he says can help us get pity and
fear in this and it's thought which is
the third most important element of
tragedy right thought he says covers all
the effects which have to be created by
speech and he tells us what the
different things are one of these is the
conveying of emotions
you know sort of equipping uh us with
emotions or the actors doing that and it
conveys it to us the audience so all of
these are ways in which pity and fear
can be aroused
he has two other really important things
to tell us here and one of these has to
do with what we actually you know are
responding to in this how do we how do
we find the events pitiable or fearful
now he's thinking about a Greek audience
here so this might not completely apply
to us so it tells us this
um
we shouldn't be showing decent people
changing from prosperity to adversity
why not because this is not fearful or
pitiable but instead repugnant something
that we find kind of gross right
um so
mieron is is the the thing there and
what does he mean by a decent person FBA
okay so you know an average kind of uh
person who's okay you know and then he
says nor should we show the depraved
changing from adversity to Prosperity
this is the least tragic of all right it
doesn't arouse uh fellow feeling or pity
or fear as a matter of fact it's likely
to make us upset or dismayed or
something along those lines we don't
want to see bad people prospering right
and the fellow feeling there is
philanthropon so it's one of the few
uses of that on an Aristotle's part so
we've eliminated two cases what about
the rest he says nor should tragedy show
the very Wicked person this
is wicked going from prosperity to
adversity why because this might arouse
fellow feeling we might be like ah you
know too bad for him but interestingly
what does Aristotle say it doesn't Rouse
pity we don't pity the terrible person
for falling into bad circumstances and
we don't feel fear why not because pity
is felt as he says for the undeserving
victim of adversity the things that are
happening to them without their being
good cause if somebody's a really
terrible person and bad things happen to
him we're like well you deserved it
buddy right and it doesn't arouse fear
because we don't identify with the
really bad person and then he says this
leaves the person who is in between
these sorts of cases this is somebody
who's not completely at the top of
virtue and justice but they do have some
right
um
they fall into adversity not through
evil or depravity kakian or mokhtherion
so kakian is actual Vice
is sort of a weakness a softness right
but why do they actually uh fall into it
because they do something stupid they
make a mistake and this is where we get
the you know fatal flaw Theory the
hamartian hamartia can mean flaw error
sin it's a very wide-ranging word but it
conveys that the person isn't totally
responsible for what they've done and so
Oedipus is a prime example of that he
also talks about theistes right so that
is one set of things that do arouse pity
and fear in US these Spectators and then
there's a little discussion later on
where he says what sort of things what
sort of incidents strike us as terrible
or you know scary or as pitiable
and he says you know if we think about
this we got three different
possibilities these can occur between
people who are connected by friendship
of some sort relationships philia or it
could be enemies right
um or it could be neither of these
people who don't really know each other
people who don't really care about each
other and he says that it's not enemies
that were primarily concerned with in a
tragedy although there could be
relations of enemies or rivalry right
and it's not people who are totally
neutral to each other it's within the
Matrix of relationships that tragedy
really occurs right he says if an enemy
acts towards an enemy there's nothing
pitiable in the deed or the prospect
except for the sufferings tragedy must
see cases where the sufferings occur
within relationships where one is about
it kills or is about to kill the other
commits some other so such deed and you
know he goes on to say you can get these
ideas from Greek myths and legends you
can't mess with the story too much but
you can you know introduce things that
actually make it scary or pity provoking
right so these are the the things that
Aristotle says about it how does it
actually produce catharsis there's a lot
of different theories out there but
Aristotle doesn't actually tell us and
so
um this is what we get pity and fear are
the two main emotions that he's
interested in we might widen this and
think about how are other emotions
involved in these plots in in the way
the actors act in the the spectacle in
the
language that is being used the thought
right all of this is is interesting and
important and ties in with this ultimate
goal of purifying or however we want to
understand catharsis dealing with these
emotions not just Within the play but
within ourselves